the Joe Rogan experience that [ __ ]
cat is so big man imagine just seeing
115 pound cake in the room with you
you'd be like oh Jesus Christ like my
dog is probably maybe 75 80 pounds
somewhere in that range he's up macho
yeah and if he wanted to kill me he
probably could right
I mean he's a golden retriever they
don't kill anything other than squirrels
mm-hmm but if he wanted to I mean I
don't know if you had that mentality he
really was like crazed like like 28 days
later he got that rage virus in her and
he just went after me all right he's got
giant ass [ __ ] teeth right I mean I
assumed that I would kick his ass
because he listens to me right because
I'm his daddy uh-huh you know I mean
like there's no he's never I had pit
bulls that growl at you a little bit and
you gotta kind of like hey [ __ ]
I'm the one who gives you your food [ __ ]
and then they'll give you their paw and
then they're sorry and you play a little
game with him a little dominance game
especially when they're teenagers and
they're like one and a half two years
old they'll test you just to check
because it's natural for them all right
it's natural for dogs
Golden's don't ever do that you know
growling anybody there just a beating
like the worst guard dog of all time man
you come over everybody he loves
everybody he loves you I love he he
loves people like he's never liked not
not like he's never met them but like he
can't believe he hasn't seen them in so
long it's like a dead long-lost friends
everyone's a long-lost friend Hilaire
and everyone everyone is a long-lost
what it's like with him he's such a love
sponge I would be jealous if I if that's
my dog I'm like so I'm not special just
that [ __ ] that's how dogs are
really friendly dogs every new person is
another opportunity for a new person to
love them too mm-hmm so they they get so
excited to meet people smart do when
people come over the house he is so
hilarious everybody loves everybody
can't believe it
and he just starts whining around in
circles it's hilarious but if you wanted
to you probably kill me I mean if a rat
was that big I would [ __ ] put my
money on the rat nothing oh right right
and dogs dogs kill rats all the time
even those little dogs like Jack
Russells those little tiny dogs those
are designed to kill rats hilarious my
ex had a dog right and I was holding the
dog so and she got into a car right
across the street and moved it and then
got out the car walk and the dog acted
like he didn't just see a jump in the
car he acted like she went away for two
days she just went to just moved the car
across to you we watched her do it
[Applause]